it's hard work I'm BuzzFeed I thought I
could be a writer but now I'm gonna tire
[Music]
can I go first
I'm gonna introduce Bobby this is Bobby
Burke interior designer on queer I'd
Netflix and not only is he a gorgeous
designer but he also has flawless typing
skills please don't stop typing he was
he's fake typing now but before he this
is Jonathan Van Ness
he is are gorgeous I'm saying gorgeous
too much but he's our gorgeous groomer
the thing that I love most about
Jonathan is he's not that groomer who is
going to tell you what you need
he's that groomer that's gonna listen to
you and help you be the best version of
what you think you should be unless
you're really out of control well then
yeah and he's gonna take control like
with my hair and Susan won he took
control of that I could do that and look
at it now hey this is Anthony he's
perfect in every way that face is
gorgeous
his cooking is gorgeous I'm just gonna
say look at that hair but I forget you
haven't washed it I washed it four days
ago this is the longest intro I've ever
known bro I think we should make a 30
minute video of us as introduced to each
other and I'm gonna introduce Kurama so
that tan can figure out how to I love
about Karim oh is that he is so in tuned
with who he is that he has managed to
take this role and really make it into
something completely different and
unexpected expert and he's got really
Tahoe a great leg look at these legs now
let's do this quiz that you're gonna
take oh my god you type like me he type
like a seven-year-old who's never seen a
computer you did your chess oh it's good
it's really good you have the good
ribbons here like a little crack a
hazelnut lube Joe is my favorite
transformation oh you know you know who
it is
well that's gonna be a question or they
miss our favorite transformation my
favorite transformation of the moment is
just because of the interaction
Bain has really gotten to you Antony it
real
I really need you to like cool it down a
little bit who was your favorite
transformation it was Jeremy because he
did the hot dogs with his kids and he
got to hang out with his kids making
condiments and the hot dogs wait season
two no cuz the question is season one
now choose a drag race Queen to be your
drag mother Jujubee you choose one for
me because I don't know jiggly Caliente
I pick a call if I'm gonna learn I'm
learned from the best
I love Jujubee for everyone I thought
she's the most like underrated of all
drag race kings of all time Jonathan
who's your other one maybe thorgy I like
I like adore Jamal no thorgy yeah I like
him he's very different Anthony I think
you are very much valentina you know
what I forgot about change
oh my god yeah it's she take the onesie
back one of these things does not belong
and if these two who don't know what
we're talking about we got to pick a
dream date and go on with your queer I
soul mate I would do a carnival for mine
you inter Conover I would recreate the
music video for all night long so you do
a music video that would be your dream
date with my husband I'd recreate it
Kurian maybe making music - bracelet
making oh that was cute that was really
she mine would be shopping for vintage
mid-century Furniture and a nice little
brunch I would do that with you know not
shopping for furniture no completely
different things Kurama you know you're
really putting people in boxes today oh
you love a picnic Oh killing my virgos
what did you say a is not Caucasian oh
my gosh everything else is capitalized
this is airing out some of our stuff I
think what they're trying to say is that
sometimes your spelling on your
Instagram captions makes the time
stressed out and they wanted to talk to
you about it for a little bit but they
get nervous
mine would be like an early made dinner
in Rome and I would have like
high-waisted trousers with my hands in
my pants just like strolling down in no
time
okay lastly choose a song to play in the
bedroom her something by her I would say
anything from Danielle Caesar
oh I'm feeling something okay who's your
goldfrapp number one
okay what's your second one Lana 13
beaches don't say anything
she's very - oh la la from gopher keep
typing don't stop typing that typing was
really working for me and he's like
giving you a gorgeous quiz moment right
now you got probably because you'd like
to keep it real you're always making
sure friends are taken care of
you prefer a night at home with your
life log friends at a chic Hollywood
party wasn't that a good one
what's your thing chroma what are you
writing I'm writing the same about you
did okay I said you got Quran because
you love being around other people you
walk into a party ready to turn up and
connect with others everyone you meet
you give a hug to you know who you are
and don't mind sharing it with the world
can I fix your grammatical and spelling
errors completely I wasn't going to
address that one senators and presidents
always have a team of people to
spellcheck their stuff so he does not
even need to tell you look fine
know what you're good I don't know what
you're not good at would you agree with
that yes okay good
what am i doing you go to yours and you
fill in why they got you do you love
avocado salad you trying to figure out
new and innovative ways to use an
avocado which is your do girl a
chocolate avocado mousse guys I can't
talk about avocado while I write you're
better type Greek yogurt it's a long
yogurt yo yo I walk in sometimes in the
morning and he's got the white yogurt
all over his face he's not even being a
nightmare and at first I like gotta go
but he does do a very gorgeous DIY Greek
yogurt it's what keeps him so balanced
Hubbs you got antony because you were a
feeler of all the fields you love a good
cheese centric meal and nothing makes
you more happy than petting a happy
pepperoni Corgi or other you love your
friends and close ones unconditionally
also baths and candles honestly if I
worked at BuzzFeed after seeing this
video I'd be like a little nervous
they're literally like making content on
the fly so Wow
like all you writers honey you need to
watch out baby I will write quizzes for
the rest of my life Tanny honestly I'm
feeling a little like oh you can type in
look pani honestly I feel like with your
to be seersucker I feel like I can't
really concentrate because because this
is creeping higher it more like
coworkers and I really you guys talked
about yourselves
never been more similar know like in
density in length I've always said that
our mustaches are the same I think you
two should grow beards or you already
have a good you should grow a beard he
has a full beard
how many girls are you doing I'm trying
to do two but they said three centons
it's one book deal suddenly one has to
wonder are these really my friends or
are they actually at nightmare [ __ ]
can't keep looking at me and typing
everyone thought that was really smart
they didn't get a clean it's like you've
never done unscripted television before
can you please look at me and type you
got it right no I didn't get it look at
me teeny and do it and really type stuff
I also love to do brow gel and a little
bit of mascara on my tips you know ten
doesn't let any I like your camo jacket
thank you
I have some really [ __ ] to pieces I'm
gonna wear for president [ __ ] well
like that you all can get away with it
because you have smaller busted me my
button that's a good beard
it would be like don't well no wait I
bet people are gonna start like asking
to get their noses done to look more
like your nose
don't is it gonna be like Jennifer
Aniston I want my nose like more like
yours right here can we talk about the
part of chance nose I'm obsessed with
this heart like how it connects into
your face like I'm obsessed with that
okay I got it I'm done you see how much
I was distracted by this one okay our
team okay you got ten because you're a
little more direct than people might
appreciate you love a strong fashion
moment you understand the importance of
dressing to get where you want to get in
life you also have a boundary a strong
appropriate boundary
Johnny come here Johnny
remember those boundaries we talked
about new thank you that yeah that
actually was really good
I'm like what's my brand like Who am I
like you are in it Johnny you are in it
the first line better be I love the king
four guys next to me over
I'd never cussed by the way got it do
you see how we didn't distract you
whilst you were doing yours all those
red lines girl I write how I talk
Jonathan as your girl because Insurance
commercials can make you cry you're
never afraid of a well-placed power
stomp and obscure sports and early 90s
MTV preferences make you feel complete
also you let people and won't let quiz
results ever dinner shine yeah I love
the subtle shade with the quiz results
sorry this will be their first and last
time having tally do their own quiz
I've been to enough auditions to know
how this works we're not getting a
callback it's fine
you need no we don't need no head -
buzzfeed.com to figure out who your soul
mate is it needs me it's similar do not
sin I walk I'm still really into it in
facets that you put on your soul mate
[Music]